Agents are going to get paranoid when that thing's in here.
Oh Dude.
It'll scare you.
Just
I believe it.
I know.
The Wolf.
Fucking yellow.
God Damn.
Eyes that fucking national.
Yeah,
it blanked.
It blanked out.
Oh God.
Let me just see.
We're now joined on stream.
Oh,
powerful stream.
That's a full live version.
Full size version of this.
God Damn Christ that things.
That was an awesome movie,
folks.
If you haven't seen it,
how dare you.
If you haven't seen American Werewolf in London is the greatest horror movie of
all time.
I love that fucking moving.
I used to think that,
but then I saw the worst horror movie of all time.
What was that funny games?
What is that?
Oh,
that's the one you were,
yeah.
It's just the,
the director said the appropriate response.
Do it as walking out halfway through.
Well,
this is a human created violence.
Scary movie,
right?
Yeah.
It's just,
it's a heart.
It's a,
it's like the I've seen,
but it's almost every harm,
but it's not monsters,
right?
Yeah.
No,
it's human.
it's not werewolves.
See I'm not interested in like mean people.
I like watching a good werewolf movie or some shit or a vampire movie.
I like watching nonsense.
Like you showing me like some guy's gonna kill somebody with a pair of pliers.
I really don't need to see that.
I know there's guys that'll do that.
Oh No,
no,
no.
This is not even like that.
This isn't like some slash reflect.
Dude.
This is like a,
according to the director,
it's commentary on the infiltration of like the mainstream media end of popular
life and they're using this like story to like to articulate it.
It's deep.
It's fucking deep.
It's about fascism.
But man,
it is like your,
your stomach will roll when you watch this fucking thing.
Highly recommended.
They say,
I only saw the US version.
Some people say that the u s version,
it's a shot for shot.
It's shot for fucking shot.
It's the guy from reservoir dogs.
What's his name?
The fucking um,
undercover cop from reservoir dogs.
Yeah.
Tim Roth is in it.
He fucking nails it.
Dude.
Guys.
Awesome.
He is awesome of Shit.
I know what's,
what's that guy do?
Does he do like planning on it seems like it probably was,
you know,
east,
he's a bad ass mother fucking actor dude.
You know what I did last night,
man,
I went to this movie theater that fucking Quintin Tarantino owns,
called the new Beverly and they show grindhouse flicks twice a month and last
night they were showing a anti drug grindhouse flit cod.
Like the acid strip or something.
What exactly is grindhouse mean?
I don't know.
I was,
I was trying to talk,
I want to Google that,
but I don't know.
Yeah,
I always wondered when I saw that,
when I saw that he was doing those movies,
the one,
uh,
with,
was a pretty girl from charmed.
The fuck is man.
I Dunno.
There was what?
They were all pretty in that show charm.
It's just fucking awesome man.
Cause it's like,
you know,
it's like the original fucking,
it's the original movie,
so it's kind of fucked up.
This had bud cort in it.
It was shot in Italy.
Yeah,
yeah.
MMM.
Rose McGowan.
That's the chick.
She was in it and she was,
uh,
she had like one leg was a gun or something like that.
Oh yeah,
I remember.
And I was like,
what the fuck is grindhouse like wait,
what is it?
It's just like an old kind of stupid,
gory,
weird kind of artistic style.
Like I think they vary.
This one was like just the stupidest,
funniest thing you've ever seen.
Like the way they try to do,
like they were trying to do the anti-drug message in the 60s and bud cort plays
this kind of rampaging hippie Weirdo.
Oh,
here's the,
here's the definition of grindhouse is an American term for a theater that
mainly shows exploitation films.
It's named after the defunct burlesque theater's located on 42nd street in New
York City where a bump and grind dancing and strip tease were featured.
Wow,
that's crazy.
So that was,
that's the old 42nd street.
That's back when New York City like,
had like a really fucked up area.
Do you remember what it was like?
Did you,
did you ever go to New York City when it was crazy?
No Way.
I've heard about it,
but I never went there.
I would,
I've been,
I was there many times when it was,
when it was still dangerous.
It was really interesting that 42nd street was there,
a completely different place.
It was this,
they decided they made like this active decision to clean that fucking place
opposite,
take out all the bullshit and make it like super like fan friendly and super,
uh,
you know,
a visitor friendly.
So w what it used to be was like one dirty little stripped ts and peep show and
triple x movie and it was fucking creepy people.
Creepy people hanging out.
Like you're like,
let's Google a old photos of,
it's like taxi driver.
It's like the movie taxi driver.
That's where I seen,
yeah,
that,
that I remember that.
I remember it was like,
I came to New York
a couple of times when I was in my teenage years and I remember being there and
wandered around called what a fucking crazy place.
This is,
man.
I had family in New Jersey and uh,
they had,
they taken me to Manhattan a few times when I was young.
I remember life,
man.
I barely remember it when I was like a little kid,
barely remember.
But I remember like feeling it's like dangerous.
Like it's so big and crazy.
It is dangerous.
But I remember when I was in my teenage years is when I saw like the peep shows
and all that shit.
I saw those,
uh,
that's,
we came there for a karate tournament.
There was a big karate tournament these do at Madison Square Garden every year.
So we came in and me and a bunch of fucking soft dorks from Boston,
you know,
Newton even where I was from the suburbs of Boston to go to this crazy fucking
city.
Like we were essentially living in Mayberry.
Compare it to like New York City.
So you have your own problems with like socially with people everywhere.
Where I,
where I grew up,
like I went to Newton south high school.
It's like the woman nice as high schools ever.
You know you're always going to have problems with human beings.
Whenever he gets 17 year olds and you mix them all together,
there's going to be progress.
But like very few fights in school,
very few like no one got really seriously injured.
You know there was like a few squabbles and people got upset with people,
but other than that it was a nice place to live.
I didn't realize how easy it had it until you're,
you're in Manhattan and you know and you're like 17 years old and you're like in
time screaming like,
what the fuck is this place?
Like this place is crazy.
It's just one person after another who wants to fuck you and give you some new
disease?
Like one it just people looking at fuck people,
people looking at jerk off and people looking to go sit and watch someone play
with their ass hole in front of you while you be,
but while you beat off in a booth and then someone cleans that like that was
time square.
Ugh.
No one cleans it there.
They did clean it.
They would go in there with a mop man.
They would do,
they would go in there with a mop and they'd look at you like you motherfucker.
I told you when I was in San Francisco I went to one of those places and I
accident like I've never been to the place where the thing goes up and you're in
like this room and there's just a bunch of people behind this glass like
fingering themselves and stuff and accidentally put my hand on the side.
Like go was like a little thing.
It was wet
too.
That's not good.
That is not good.
And like the guy who was like,
I was like,
oh I think I just put my hand and common cause oh no.
We cleaned those things every in between every person.
And then I just watched people going in and out and I was like,
no you don't.
And watching people how you play your hand.
Yeah,
it's just cells.
Don't worry about it man.
Cause you had to choose between a guy punching you in the head or jizzing on
your face.
What would you pick?
Punching in the head?
I would take the gels in the face all day.
You know,
why would you do dunk?
You know why?
Because I'll tell you why.
Because A,
I've been
punched in the face and it's not fun.
And B,
I've accidentally come in my face and it was not that bad.
Oh,
it was delicious.
It was,
no,
it wasn't delicious,
but it wasn't nothing that hurt,
you know,
it was pretty,
pretty pain free.
It was warm.
You know,
when I was like 16,
I was uh,
you know,
I was completely retarded.
Of course I was using the pullout method.
I might also teenage girlfriend,
we didn't know what the fuck word and we're idiots.
We shouldn't have been alone together.
So,
uh,
I would pull out and one time I pulled out and I shot it so far and hit me in
the face.
Like I was like looking down at it as I pulled it out,
I guess I wanted to see how much came out and it hit me right in the Mug flat
and I was like,
wow.
So that's what it feels like.
It was kinda exciting.
Put Yourself,
put yourself in the girl's position.
It feels like,
why do we want a hot load in the face?
It's hot,
you know,
like God represents,
represents the man's passion on your face.
Not that I want it from anyone other than me.
Doesn't sound like it at all.
Oh,
it only happened once.
This other things that it only happened once then I'm shocked with one of them
is um,
beating off in the car.
I've only been off in the car once in my entire driving.
Yeah.
One time when I was living in Boston,
I was working for a Limo Company and uh,
I was driving home and it was a long ride and it was horny.
So I just beat off.
It was just like something to do and a,
I just squirted a load inside my shirt,
tucked it back of my pants.
Yeah.
And then,
you know,
I remember doing it and I remember thinking,
well,
all right,
so here's some new fucked up thing I do now because I figured I would just keep
doing that.
No,
I'd never jerked off in the car before and be in like 20 years old or whatever.
I was at the time,
I was like,
what an idiot I did.
You really just start jerking off in the car because that's what you're going to
start doing all the time now.
Dummy.
And I didn't,
for whatever reason,
I never did it again.
Like what do you mean?
Like that would become your fetish.
Like jerking.
Yeah,
I figured if I found one other place where I was comfortable jerking off,
that's not a good thing.
You know what I mean?
Because have jerked off at work before
God.
Imagine a world where jerking off was just normal and like,
do you just like,
you know,
in line people are jerking off.
One time I jerked off at work twice because I this really hot date that night
and I jerked,
I was doing construction.
I was in his basement that would the,
we're building this house and uh,
I would just open the door,
beat off onto the Dr
and then go back to work.
I did it twice.
That's how fucked up I was.
And then when I went on the date that night with the girl,
I was like barely into it.
And I was like,
I'd wanted to fuck this girl for so long and we finally ran into each other
somewhere and I was like,
Holy Shit.
And she was so down,
but I was like barely hard.
It was so sad.
I had a complete three quarters erection.
You've fucked up.
And she was the first girl that wanted to put her finger in my ass.
I was like,
well you never forget that lady.
She goes,
I know what you want.
It's,
this is what she said.
She goes,
I know what you want.
We were both like 17 or something like that.
I go,
what it,
what do I want?
She goes,
you want me to stick my finger in your ass?
I was like,
Whoa,
what the f how wrong or you yeah,
like that you couldn't be more wrong.
Yeah.
That's more like what you want but automatically I want,
I didn't want a Griller,
you know,
cause that's kind of rude to do a girl you're dating,
but you don't want to go.
How many dudes have you stuck your finger up their ass can cause if you just
offer that up like the first time we hook up and just offer up a finger up the
ass and you're only 17 I think maybe like maybe I was 18 and she was 17 or 19
and 18 one of the in the,
in that range,
you know,
right after high school or around that it's like she's already done this.
How many times I wonder how many dudes buttholes this girl's uh,
just,
I know what you want.
I was like,
yeah,
you know,
go for it baby.
Like just on a whim,
on a hope that it's a good thing.
Yeah.
And all of a sudden she's sucking on her fingers and you going,
where's this going?
See in the world of Kurzwell that we're talking about,
the idea that you're going to be able to record everything,
there will be a way that you can act and the way that,
like guys will hack into their girlfriend's email.
You'll be able to hack into your girlfriends like past,
like see a scan of like you could actually just enter it in.
How many buttholes is her finger been improved?
28.
It's a,
I'm reading that sexist.
Go on a book.
I'm reading this sex is pretty good.
Yeah,
it's fascinating.
And one of the things that I find fascinating is all the different theories
about why people act and behave certain ways when it comes to like sexual,
like uh,
how many sexual partners has your wife had.
Yeah.
Why it's so important that you limit that number.
That you can trust her and keep our Ra.
It's really fascinating stuff,
man.
Oh Man.
That book is incredible.
I love that guy.
Good.
That's a really cool dude too.
Chris Ryan,
he's bred him on your podcast twice.
Twice.
Yeah.
Get in touch with him and try to see if he'll do this.
Cause he,
he's uh,
he's really very interesting.
I love the part about the Yucatan,
the name of the Yucatan.
Do you remember that part?
I don't remember that.
The they,
when Columbus is people or Cortez of came to the Yucatan,
they asked the people like,
what?
What do you call this place?
And they made this sound,
not that sound,
but they made the sound like we could talk her at home,
you know,
and the guy said you could tighten close enough caught.
So they say we're going to call it the Yucatan.
Well,
it turned out that the Mayan scholars,
after all those years of deciphering they,
they do that.
What he was trying to say was,
I don't understand what you're saying.
That's what he was saying,
that they had taken to you to talk to Larry.
Isn't that amazing?
Yeah.
That's such an amazing,
like I love knowing shit like that,
like house and then knowing that that was only a few hundred years ago.
Right.
That's really kind of nuts.
W we're so spoiled by the time that we arrived,
you know,
we're,
we're so spoiled that being alive in the year 2012 like just a few hundred years
ago,
there was people that in boats and just traveled and didn't know where the fuck
they were going.
And had no idea what they would find and didn't have it
math.
But Dude,
think about what is it 500 years ago.
I love to think about that and I love to think about that fucking feeling,
that feeling that,
that that's a feeling.
I mean,
we can find that.
yeah,
you could,
you know,
esoterically say,
we can search into the world of psychedelics for new lands or,
yeah.
But no one is ever going to know until interstellar travel happens.
No one's ever going to know that fucking feeling of being on a ship and for the
first time seeing land in a place where no one knows there's land.
Yeah.
And the idea that you would have the audacity to go look in the ocean,
to not know what's on the other side,
to just go out there like,
oh my God,
you had to have fucking tremendous balls.
Yeah.
And the,
the,
that was one of the things,
it must've been amazing back then was the ability to see the stars.
Like as long as it wasn't cloudy out,
you could really see everything because there was no light pollution where if
you,
if you've ever been in the country in the middle of the night,
oh yeah.
To look up and on a clear night and just see a fucking unbelievable amounts of
stars.
It really makes you sad that that's not a regular feature like that.
What we've done by creating these beautiful cities and these safe roads to
travel on,
we've disconnected ourselves from the vision of the cosmos of our part in the
cosmos.
Yeah.
When you're like in the country,
man,
you're staying in a farm and you go like kick back in a hammock and you look up
and the entire sky is filled with stars.
That is a perspective enhancing experience.
That's a visual psychedelic staring at the stars is a very visual psychedelic.
Well,
I mean you've got like white pouring into your eyes.
Yeah.
From the far reaches of the universe.
You're,
you've got light coming into your eyes.
It's from,
so like it's so long ago
you,
you're getting that feeling that you get when you see something beautiful that
we seek out beautiful things which we seek out them,
whether their flowers or sculptures or a person or car.
There's something that strikes us when we see something beautiful.
You know,
it's all subjective to each person.
Whenever they're beautiful is it he lights that charge in their mind?
Yeah.
I'll give you ever seen a guy who's like really into old cars and he sees an old
corvette or something like that.
Oh this is a 67 look at the lines on this baby and you see him like his fucking
eyes light up and like these,
there's a charge that a person gets from a thing of beauty,
from seeing something that's
beautiful.
There's an idea that that thing of beauty is lying underneath everything that
the world is just covering that beauty up and that people use objects as a way
to limit the beauty because to,
to like really accept the whole thing is like would be so potent that you start
off like getting that feeling from cars or you start off getting that feeling
from looking up at the sky or you start off getting that feeling from falling in
love.
But like that feeling is like underneath everything,
that's what everything is composed of is that sense of like,
wow,
holy shit.
Cause that's like a peak.
That's a peak feeling,
that feeling of being like whatever the thing is,
the activates it.
Sometimes I think that maybe that's what enlightenment is,
is when you just hit that feeling perpetually.
You're just perpetually in that space of like,
wow,
this is amazing.
I,
uh,
I had a friend who was like really into Buddhism and she had this thing on her
wall that said,
uh,
Lightman is enlightenment is possible in this lifetime.
Yeah.
And I remember reading that going,
wow,
that is a profound statement.
You know,
enlightenment is possible in this lifetime.
And I remember thinking like,
wow,
what a,
what a weird thing we all have in our heads is this,
this burning desire to get shit together.
Like everybody would love to be enlightened.
You know,
be aware of anybody who tells you they are,
be aware of anybody,
tells you they don't want to be.
Wow.
That's great.
Yeah.
Just made that up.
That's great dude.
That's really good.
It's delicious.
Yeah.
It's a gift from the university.
That,
that really is.
I'm sure somebody's probably already said it so
already.
Yeah.
That's big.
That's too good.
I couldn't have made that one up.
No,
I've never heard it before.
I've heard it.
If you see the boot on the road,
kill him.
I've never heard the where of anybody who says they're enlightened or who says
they don't want to be
pretty good when you talk to people and they have this box that they don't want
to operate in a
real,
live and die.
That's like our,
our thing.
We did and you and I broke down that country western.
Oh yeah.
You know?
Yeah.
That ridiculous.
A NDA girl,
but happy to be a single celled organism.
Anybody who wants to change that,
you've got to come through me.
Yeah,
yeah man.
It's that,
that kind of Co,
you know,
constricted life sucks for the person who's living in the constricted life and
for the people living around the person and the constricted life and it's like
you can,
if you just play around with that fucking idea that you can permanently,
permanently shift your consciousness so that you are experiencing life in the
way that like those however many times you've had to happen in your life.
Some people more,
sometimes last when you're for the first time you like accomplish some big thing
and you get that sense of like,
oh my God,
man,
I can fucking,
I can really do shit that I didn't think I could do.
That feeling is like the universe at that moment unfolds.
It's like a whole new room,
a whole new giant land pops open and your subjective universe.
We were like,
wow,
there's an entire other part of this life I had no idea about.
Well,
it's like if you can always be in that state of recognizing that this is the
most beautiful peak experience that could happen to anything,
which I think is what enlightened people,
the people I've been around,
you are.
Yeah,
very advanced.
I wouldn't call them enlightened.
They're just happy man.
They're just like hobbies,
the wrong word for it though.
They're like connected and there
really,
really
not afraid to express love.
You know?
They're very,
they're feeling love all the time.
I think that that's a cool idea that you could feel that all the time.
I think that's a beautiful idea that you could be in that place all the time.
If you're careful about your friends,
you know,
and you,
you only surround yourself with positive people.
I think you worked out,
I think you can do that all the time.
It's all about constructing that environment though.
You know,
you have to like do that by sharp editing throughout,
throughout your entire life.
You've got to figure out how to edit yourself and edit people.
Right.
You know,
you've got to figure out how to get,
get the most,
like they'll,
they'll get rid of as many of your own negative instances.
Any of those that you can get away with,
not,
not causing yourself,
like minimize that,
tried to get it down to zero.
We're none.
None of the negative moments are created because of your actions and figure out
who's creating all those other negative moments and eliminate the interaction
with those people.
I mean,
if you can do that and then find likeminded folks who will not put anything,
try not to do anything negative to their friends and don't want to accept
anything negative either.
The near about,
around a bunch of people who love each other.
Let me throw out an idea because this is what you're talking about.
It's something that some hippie bullshit will start to calm.
You ain't hippy bullshit,
man.
This is like the idea of like,
well,
in the beginning,
you know,
there's,
there's uh,
uh,
the beginning of spiritual life is what they say.
They say the beginning of spiritual life is like a tea,
like a,
a tendril like uh,
uh,
the beginning of like when a tree grows,
right?
And when a trees growing at first,
uh,
the most gigantic trees started off as a tiny little fucking sprig.
So when you're in that place,
it's really important to keep shit out.
They can like fuck you up.
And that's the idea of cutting people out or like cutting out the negative
elements.
But then there's this other idea that I was listening to some Ron doss lecture.
He's talking about reactivity and that when you're around someone who's got a
difficult personality or someone who's like an instigator,
a drama vortex,
you still get to decide if you're going to be reactive to that person or not.
You still get to be in control of the way you feel around that person.
But in the beginning,
that person can make you feel like shit when you're around an asshole.
Your mood will drop,
your mood shifts,
you get mad,
you get unhappy,
you feel threatened.
But the idea is,
is as you advance in gain more and more control of your consciousness,
then that stops happening.
So you use that asshole as an emotional gym.
Yes.
You use them as an emotional or a psychological growth sparring partner.
Yeah.
And as you deal with their Douchey Enos,
you learn how to better navigate Douche Enos throughout your life.
Yeah.
And also for the first time when the asshole is around someone who isn't
reacting to them being an asshole,
they're going to be like,
what the fuck is this?
Cause then if their whole life they've been going through life,
getting cues from people like,
Oh I don't think so.
No.
Right.
So all of a sudden if they're around someone who's like beaming,
you know,
beaming and the way that they,
you would be beaming around when you saw it.
Like when Joey Diaz walks into a room,
you're beaming that way around a cunt.
Suddenly they're like,
what the fuck is this?
Well the real problem though is when they become physically violent,
when you have dump constant wanna Punch you,
that's when you run into a real situation.
Yes.
But how often did,
I mean that doesn't happen that most of the time,
but you've managed to surround yourself with,
you know,
hipsters.
I mean if you're in certain parts of the country,
certain parts of a city,
you can,
you get punched in the face randomly.
I've seen it.
Terror.
There's a terrible video,
a woman in London,
some guy just comes and cracks are for no reason.
It's not that they're looking for the guys,
some teenage girls knocked unconscious,
demonic son of a bitch.
It's just fucked up that people are capable of doing shit like that and that
there's,
there's the broad spectrum of the possible human actions.
It's so broad.
I mean,
you could be a god that she could have crossed paths with a guy who was like,
good morning,
you know,
top of the day to you and been real happy and made her feel really good and she
could have moved on to,
you know,
her job or whatever,
feeling like really good.
Instead she runs into the wrong guy and he cracks or knocks her unconscious for
nos for no reason whatsoever.
She hits her head on the concrete.
I saw it,
dude,
she's out but horrible.
You know what's amazing,
man?
This is again,
that shit we were talking about in the beginning.
This is the shift that's happening because there was a time in human history
when a thug go galloping up behind some young last in the street and knock her
down and like the entire planet doesn't know about it in a matter of like eight
hours,
you know this,
this is them.
This is the incredible time that we're in is that that it's a double edged
sword.
You see something like that and you,
you're,
you're either going to be like,
God damn,
this is a fucked up world or living in I,
there's guys we'll just run up behind someone and punch him in the head.
Or the other side of it is like,
fuck in one,
you know,
a day or two,
this act of violence has been broadcast all over the planet and has created a
situation where people could like talk about how awful it is and how,
how,
how bad that is that people are like that and it,
I think that elevates us a little bit.
I think it just takes a lot more time than we're used to it because we're used
to like processing power going up in a year and a hard drive space doubling.
Yes,
we're used to all these massive improvements and then we,
we don't see that in human nature.
And it's really frustrating,
you know,
I think that this,
this,
you know,
shifting,
we keep saying,
I think it's just more subtle than people would like,
it's not as fast as a going from a,
an old tube television to a 55 inch flat screen.
It's not,
you know,
it's not,
it's something difference between having Dsl and,
you know,
having a,
56 k,
you know,
it's,
it's too small.
It was like,
so when we still see these versions of the worst case scenarios of human
behavior,
it's shocking to us that they still exist,
but I think the direction is for them to exist less.
It seems like more and more as part of the shift,
things are standing out that aren't shifting more and more so like,
you know,
like Romney for example,
or like,
uh,
these like crazy fucking like,
you know,
homophobic antiabortion Republicans talking about my family.
Boy,
he's crusty old sons of bitches.
More and more are starting to look like monsters there.
They're starting to look more like freaks a whereas they used to be able to
like,
you know,
they used to be able to turn fucking high powered water hoses on crowds of black
people.
You know,
that without,
without losing their jobs.
You know what I mean?
Like,
so this,
this shift is like,
but it's really interesting to watch the way that a lot of these crusty old
pundits are reacting to it.
Man.
They're having the same effect that when they threw water on the witch and the
wizard of Oz,
you know,
that kind of like they're hissing and shrieking and they don't how to deal with
it.
What's fascinating to me is that with this,
with this new sort of a understanding of people that were getting,
because of the Internet,
there's water all over me.
I spilled coffee on me.
I have a nice shirt and I don't want to ruin it with this new,
this new understanding that people have of like
having the access to these kinds of stories,
having the access to these horrible stories that are things that are happening
from the Gaza Strip,
that this shift that's going on.
Like as it's happening,
all these horrific things that still exists in the world,
they seem to escalate almost as if they're worried that something's coming out.
I'm almost as if like,
it's the,
the,
you know,
uh,
fundamentalism gets even more and more extreme and more and more hate for more
and more crazy and you start getting shit like Dodd hates fags and guys holding
up the fucking sign.
They have a whole website dedicated to it.
And like all of that,
that the hate that you see with,
you know,
w we had um,
uh,
on the podcast we had this conversation with Shane Smith about Pakistan and
India and the potential for nuclear war and it was one of the scariest
conversations ever because these people like,
it's like almost like a lost state like Pakistan who was talked to him like how
chaotic it is and how chaotic the rulership is and how they hate Indian India
hates them and that different leaders have said they wanted a strap themselves
to a nuclear bomb and go over there and blow the other people up like that.
This all exists at the same time as these,
this new understanding of this new shift.
It's almost like it's this resistance and it's almost like this thing that we
have to rally against,
like the most fucked up part of human nature.
It's like we have to rally against that and that's what Unites People
[inaudible] otherwise we'd be too lazy or the ones we have to it,
we would accept mediocrity.
We would accept a certain slow tempo to the evolution of human consciousness.
But this forces it to act.
I could all the evil and all the fucked up,
the actions of the world and fucking drone attacks and all this craziness forces
us to act and think,
well it's again man.
Yes I agree.
Like in,
you know,
there's part of me that gets scared cause I feel like that thing gets backed
into a corner and its size,
the press,
the button.
But I think what's really,
what's happening is an amplification effect.
I think acts of violence are becoming
less but becoming more amplified because we're so,
we're becoming so much more appalled at the idea of like,
uh,
the,
the barbarism of war and all this shit that humans do.
Uh,
I think that,
that,
that what's happening is God hates fags.
These people pop up,
right?
And then what happens though,
people organized from the Internet and suddenly God hates fags is whenever,
wherever they go,
they get surrounded by mobs,
holding signs.
God hates signs.
God hates this.
God hates that giant signs blocking them out.
So it's like the hate is getting absorbed.
It's getting up.
It's not working,
it's not working.
It just seems like it's horrible because it's being broadcast to so many people,
but the way people are reacting,
that's what's important.
That's what's important.
As long as people are reacting,
you know that's the number one thing and not ignoring it.
That's great.
And as long as people were reacting in whatever way,
just fucking as simple as the thing is like just tweeting,
just tweeting something,
re tweeting something about some of the violence that's happening.
Just anything to get the information out there and keep that fucking pop
bubbling.
That's Great Matt.
That'll that,
that will continue to push the warmongers into the periphery and I think that
the the there,
what just happened with Romney and fucking Obama,
I think,
well we're lucky we look what's going on with Egypt with a new president decided
to give himself all power.
Yes,
I'll all powerful,
but look what's happening.
Even their look what's happening.
It's not what it is not working.
It's not fucking working.
That stuff doesn't,
isn't working in the way it used to work.
And that's the shift.
The mojo that these fucking old white dudes used to have is fading.
It's fading away,
man.
It's like,
it feels like the magic is leaving them,
which is why it's so beautiful.
When you watched Karl Rove on Fox News having a little like wizard of Oz style
man behind the curtain meltdown as he realizes that his evil scheme to try to
get Romney and the power,
it didn't fucking work.
Yeah.
That's cool,
Danny,
isn't it?
That's cool.
That's was like,
no though the numbers are wrong.
The numbers are wrong.
Yeah.
He wouldn't admit it,
man.
He wouldn't admit to defeat.
Yeah.
It's great to watch and a lot of them are like it.
That's what's happening is they,
they don't want to admit they,
they're always upholding the virtues of this country and how we come from
revolution,
but when the real revolution starts happening,
they're like,
I'm going to succeed now.
I'm going to succeed because the real revolution isn't a revolution where we all
get to hide in our shacks and collect our fucking gun.
Yeah.
Look at this flower is photos,
200,000 Egyptians and they're protesting.
What's crazy is they're protesting around an ancient obelisk from,
you know,
the dynastic Egypt.
It's just incredible stone mystery that's covered in hieroglyphs.
And these people are protesting around it and screaming and yelling that you
can't have fucking you.
We,
we,
we're done.
Like we elected someone.
The idea is that we're now in a democracy.
You cannot have this crazy to autograph,
but he wants to,
he wants to say that he can't get arrested.
He can't go.
Jay like,
can't be treating word.
Look at that.
Didn't work asshole.
Amazing though that he would want to do that.
And he says it's because of his opposition.
Cause his opposition would try to do terrible and Muslim Brotherhood it.
Well,
he's the Muslim.
The Muslim Brotherhood is what's in power now.
I at least I believe so.
I believe that's how it goes.
For some reason.
I don't think that,
but I don't know.
I haven't,
I don't know.
I might right.
I,
well here it goes pro a protest or stormed the headquarters of the Muslim
Brotherhood and the country's second largest city of,
yeah.
They know that some Muslims,
the Muslim Brotherhood is this guy wanted to uh,
do something where he didn't have any,
uh,
there was,
he had no,
no worries whatsoever about ever being arrested in this actually could be a
dictator.
You want wanted to be a dictator,
right?
They're like,
no,
because this isn't working.
Sorry.
It's the same thing as like when it's just,
whenever you start letting freedom out of the bottle,
man,
you're not going to get the freedom back.
And once people feel that sense of like,
Holy Shit,
if we get together,
we can change things in a big way.
Yeah.
You're not going to be suddenly they're going to be like,
all right,
we are okay.
We'll let you be the new dictator.
It's like,
no man.
We've learned.
We've learned how to change things through the group mind.
Do you think it's possible though that moving forward we're ever going to get to
a position of no.
W.
W we'll have no one above anyone else.
No one in a position of like president or where they can take executive
privilege.
Like Obama did that with that whole gun running thing with that whole,
you know,
that whole,
uh,
what the fuck they call it fast and furious.
Yes.
Or they sold guns to the Mexican drug lords just to track them.
And those guns want to being used on American citizens.
Like it doesn't make any sense.
The,
the store makes no sense.
Like their story that they would sell guns to the Mexican drug lord,
so they get tracked the guns.
That's one of the dumbest fucking ideas I've ever heard in my life.
You're going to arm them with thousands of guns so that you could track those
guns.
Right.
Who Do you think they got to do with?
Those guns are going to kill people.
That's the craziest idea of overheard.
Stupid.
It almost like that's their excuse.
Like that's what they're going to say and they have it planned out and make it
look like that's the doing.
But really what they're doing is they're profiting on selling guns.
Cut that because Dave and they're just playing dumb.
Yeah,
that makes a lot more sense to me.
It doesn't make any sense to me that someone would think that selling criminals
guns is a good idea because then you could track the guns like what the fuck are
you talking about,
dude?
I mean that's a problem.
That shit gets so obscured by,
like they,
they have so many great ways of like diffusing information of adding information
to information that's not real of subtracting shit that it becomes that who the
fuck knows what is right.
Yeah.
When it becomes a part of,
you know,
like the government where the president doesn't have to yes.
Get tried on this.
The,
the,
he can invoke this executive privilege.
He doesn't have to testify that's squirrely.
That shit.
Squirly never,
I don't think there's ever a time where anyone,
she'd be able to say like,
oh,
I had something to do with that whole guns being sold to fucking crazy people
who kill people on a regular basis.
But I don't want to talk about it.
Like,
you either knew about it or you didn't know that.
Well,
it's like we hired you,
bitch.
You gotta talk about it.
And if you knew
about it and you didn't do anything about it,
that's incompetence.
That's crazy.
If you let that fly,
if Obama let that fly,
like that's one of the dumbest things a president could ever approve ever.
Sure.
What we should know,
we should know whether or not,
especially in a time of a reelection when that was going on and there's just no
way he shouldn't have to say,
well I thought it was a good idea at the,
they assured me these guns
would this fire,
you know,
there was no,
or like Romney's tax returns like that shit.
Like that kind of information should be all on the table.
Yeah.
You should know how much
she paid in taxes because you know how rich he is.
And if you really did weasel it out and then the last couple of years decided to
start paying a lot of taxes to,
to show,
you know,
so he had it on paper.
If you're running for the office like that.
Yeah.
I mean that's that the idea is,
you know,
to change this fucking businessman,
president and delight public servant President.
That's,
that's the idea that you want.
You want the fucking guy like runs.
Cost Guard is set.
Rather than saw this thing on Reddit,
the guy who runs Costco pays his employees like $18 an hour minimum.
They have health insurance and he only makes $500,000 a year.
This is the guy who fucking runs Costco.
Like think about that.
Meanwhile,
the guy who runs Walmart is like something out of fucking pink Floyd the wall.
He's just some a pig man.
He's like,
Aye.
You know what I mean?
It's crazy.
But that's the shift,
man.
We want more things shifting to that so that you get the Costco version of the
fucking president.
That's like,
yeah.
You know,
I'm really just in this because I'm trying to make this,
this country prosperous and the people in this country have as much access to
like healthcare and what they need to live really great lives.
So more Richard Branson,
less less Rupert Murdoch.
Yes.
These old fucking warlock pigs,
man.
Drive them into the shadows.
Warlock pigs.
That'd be an awesome name for a band.
Yeah,
man,
we need more Branson's interstellar travel.
We need more fucking Steve Jobs.
You know,
we need more fucking like more of that running the show and I think that's going
to happen more and more.
Well you know what I'm really impressed with when you talk to people that work
for Google,
when you talk to people that work for Google and they tell you what a great
company is to work for it and how well they're treated and like the the
facilities are there.
Campus,
I guess they call it a campus.
Yes.
You know,
you hear those kinds of stories like you know that it's possible that a company
can operate like that.
Dude,
any kind of super,
anyone who's plugging into this vibe that's happening right now,
whatever the fuck this thing is,
man,
you know right away that's all about connectivity and you know right away that
the feeling you get from like giving more than you're supposed to give is such
an awesome feeling and that feeling,
that state of mind where you're putting out more than you're supposed to be
putting out,
it seems like in that state of mind is where the bigger ideas come from anyway.
It's like that's creating a fertile ground and your consciousness to open up for
like the big ideas,
but if you're shut down,
closed down,
if you're fucking,
if you're,
if you're just one big human muscle spasm,
pushing all your gyms into the black pit of the your life,
you know,
hoarding and hiding and concealing,
then you're shut down.
That's when you turn into Donald Trump with his dumb ass tweets
who sillier than that guy.
I just,
you
pay attention to that shit,
Brian.
Yeah,
I don't like the guy anymore.
I used to like him a lot,
but he just seems like it's a crazy kook now.
Yeah.
Right.
Like something happens.
Something like he shifted.
Is that try water.
Thanks the way we have everything set up.
This is stupid.
I know.
I'm gonna see you sweetie.
We should put a TV on the other side of this monitor.
Yeah.
You could be making funny faces at me.
I wouldn't even know.
How dare you.
We're still working this place out ladies and gentlemen.
Um,
my mic sounds weird.
It sounds like I'm a robot.
Sounds fine.
Dot.
That sounds.
Sounds,
it sounds okay to you.
The Lakers knowing that you don't like them,
but you're wearing their headsets.
They're getting mad and are all Skullcandy gave us these are there thanks called
candy.
Did you have the bill burr ones down there?
Bill Baer ones?
Oh yeah.
In a box itself.
Celtics.
Uh,
they,
they have them I guess for basically every,
are these good headsets man.
I've,
I've been real close to forking out.
I'll give you a pair of these.
I've got awesome.
Yeah.
I'll Skullcandy has been sending them to us 40 bucks.
Yeah,
they're expensive.
They're good though.
These they sound fucking wicked.
Yeah,
they uh,
they sent me this whole email explaining how they,
uh,
spent a lot of money on research and development to try to make like really good
sounding ones that initially they were more of like a lifestyle company.
They had like good ones,
but now they're concentrated on really creating like something that like a Dj
would listen with.
I leave fucking ear buds scattered across this fucking country like spider
threat and chargers,
chargers in fucking ear buds.
Everywhere I go.
Trail on rights and sunglasses.
I lost my Goddamn I pad.
I lost my fucking digital recorder.
I'm like a fucking a 11 year old would like bad add at a summer camp on this
last tour I did.
I left shit everywhere.
Well See,
first of all
saying this last tour,
whenever you go on tour man,
like you're going from one hotel room to another hotel.
You're lucky if you keep 80% of your shit.
It's amazing how much you lose dude.
It's amazing.
Do you feel bad?
Not that I do this,
but I think you might do it.
Do you like?
Do you feel guilty when you,
like when you like Jizz in a hotel room and like what do you throw the tissue
down?
Have you ever done that and you realize you will have to fuck what are you wipe
it in?
Do you feel bad?
But you know what I mean?
Like I feel bad for the maids man.
Like,
like all the fuck hit them.
The maids.
I just started fucking tip in the movie too.
I didn't even know you were supposed to do that.
I that's something I just woke up too.
Yeah.
I like,
yeah I just started doing that.
But unfortunately for many,
many maids if like had to pick up a crusty old thing and like they them
sucked on the Napkins.
A
gemara model now taking your salty that's what they,
that's what they feed on.
Yeah.
Like a Gnat.
Washcloth just sucking on the washcloth,
fight over them.
I'm in the bathroom and she doesn't know that you used your keys to get back in
because she didn't hear the door open cause she's making that sucking noise.
Bang.
She's like on top of it,
like a praying mantis eating a fucking bomb.
Pirates slowly starting to bring color back to her face.
God vampires were so close to being awesome man.
If only they want to just,
well that would be the sucky best.
It would be attached to your dick and balls with like knife,
like teeth so that you were scared to move so you lay there and terror and you
would just shoot a load out of pure fear and they would just keep it and they
wouldn't let you pull it out.
He's done.
You know that feeling like after you come where you want to like somebody
touches your Dick like hey I like it tickles almost like it's too crazy blow
job.
If a giant sucky booths with teeth is attaching itself to the head of your Dick
and suck on it and you can't pull your Dick back.
Cause if you do it gets shredded and you feel the Stinger on your neck kind of
push in a little bit.
Yeah,
he started struggling too much.
Giant Stinger like a,
like a scorpion like comes over the top of your head.
So while you're blowing it wide sucking your Dick,
it's,
its Stinger is like attached to your spine and you're looking at in this weird
cave,
it's dragged you into it and it's just all like whether dude corpses and maybe a
couple of guys still alive and the Stinger has two vice like tentacles and
either side of that clamp down on your neck.
So right before it pushes that sting against your spine.
Those things get tighter and tighter and you just feel it,
you know,
don't go anywhere.
I'm sucking your deck and this is going to go on for five years.
Giant teeth.
I never pictured them at like that.
Like when I think of a sack of us,
I think a world of Warcraft is fucking hot chick with like leather boots,
like a dominatrix or the little whip that like you know,
over fuck to you.
But if it starts out as a beautiful girl and then you realize in the middle of
having sex with it,
like sort of like Jack Nicholson when he was making out with that lady and the
shining and then all sudden she was like a hundred years old with cancer all
over her back.
Maybe that's how it gets cone and maybe it looks like Rose McGowan and then you
move in for the kill.
You start squeezing her ass and all of a sudden she morphs into this thing.
Yeah,
just your,
you can't move.
I think that's why I have to hold your neck and then it starts talking to you
off.
Yeah.
I think that's the story.
Fucking wives man.
It is.
And it always starts off like that.
Next thing you know,
you're over your clamped in to some kind of that to me it's a symbol,
you know,
it's like that.
Oh the sirens that like seeing in the sailors crashed their ships on the island
and you know,
it's all the same fucking story.
Right?
How come guys don't see those in prison?
Like,
you know some girl with like fake girl with a key that's going to let you out.
Do you,
you never hear of like crazy hallucinations in prison?
I don't know about that.
I'm,
I'm pretty sure there's some pretty crazy illuminations in prison.
Yeah.
But I mean like that kind of reoccurring theme of like a,
someone with a light near the rock's going,
come on over here.
I own a sailor's smashed into the rock.
So the prison harpies there's prison harpies man I called trainees.
We had 'em
Victor Conte on,
he was telling us about his time in a minimum security prison where you were
allowed like really allowed to leave whenever you want.
Like people would come and pick up their,
their family like Elana stay there a certain amount of time you could get like
passes to leave.
He said that the security guards,
like there was a girl security guard.
They would make money prostituting herself.
Yeah.
Like you could go get some head from the security guard.
She made a lot of extra money that way.
It makes sense to me.
These poor bastard Italian,
but not going to let these guys,
fuck man.
That's why there's so many problems.
It's,
it's awesome,
man.
I would add that to the God damn constitution.
If you're in prison,
you get a blow job a month just to,
because
you got to be around some crazy fucking people that want to kill women.
What if you're around some really crazy serial murderer character and someone's
got to suck his dick?
Who's job should that be?
I mean
another serial murderer.
A guy.
Yeah,
whatever.
Dude,
who cares?
This is a fucking hole in the wall.
You know what's on the other end?
It's like you make it very like dad's guys would bite each other's dicks off.
There's no way you fucking Defang them.
You can't Defang a guy cause he's on the other end.
If he grabs a hold of it,
she said he just pulls it out with his hands.
I haven't perfected this system yet,
but I'm working on it.
But because if he couldn't blow you with his hands,
be an inferior blowjob moving through a hole in the wall,
you can feel like,
what the fuck?
Let me just take it down from this disgusting level it's gotten.
If you heard about the new program where they give prisoners kittens,
if you heard about this.
Yeah,
I have heard.
And it makes them like,
what's that?
What's a good way a cat?
And so sat down to two of my pets.
I have one left dude.
Um,
yeah,
it's really cool.
But it's like,
just like having these fucking cats is changing the prisoner's behavior and
massive ways,
man,
because they know that if they get in fights,
they lose their cat so they don't want to fucking lose the cat.
So it's like,
it creates this like it,
it adds piece.
You've got to bring love into prison.
That's a problem,
man.
Love is the answer.
Brother.
With a little fucking kitten can transform some hardcore thug and to somebody
who's like,
you know,
I'm not going to fight because princess is back in the saddle and I don't want
to lose her.
That's love,
man.
That's the most powerful thing.
It's a lot more powerful than being like,
oh,
we'll put you in solitary.
Can Fuck you.
Fuck up.
How many of these guys are actually fucking the cat though a lot.
Most of them,
right?
Yeah.
Maybe the cat is like a special attachment.
When you stick your Dick in its ass and alarm goes off you to the RFID chip,
you push,
you push the button when your cock to try to fuck a cat,
you're not going to have a fucking cat.
It's like they probably do an operation on the cap where there's like,
there's like a little toggle and as long as the poops going that way it passes
the toggle.
It doesn't go off.
But if a dick goes in the other way,
click it hits the switch and then the RFID chips signals the alarm as a cat.
That's a fleshlight in prison.
Yeah,
they would fuck that guy.
I think prisoners,
staff flashlights,
man.
I don't know why we're acting like it's going to do anything good to like try to
like change someones libido.
Who's in a cage.
Like that's not going to add happiness to a prison or peacefulness.
Everyone you look at these prison riots are like,
why are they writing to?
They're not,
they're not fucking,
these guys have so much testosterone and then you're not letting them fuck.
Yeah,
but even if you
give him flashlights,
so it's not as good as raping a guy.
That's part of the fun for them.
I think it's holding someone down and,
and getting that man pussy,
you know?
I mean when,
when they're turning out to each other,
that's part of what they're doing.
Okay.
No disagree.
[inaudible] way you phrase that.
I'd like to be punched in the face and a flashlight.
Yeah,
no shit man.
Dude.
I saw a terrifying thing ever seen that thing of that dude is like the,
like the toughest prisoner and like Columbia.
Have you ever seen that thing?
And he's just like,
yeah,
that guy's a monster.
And he's like,
yeah,
I make a man.
My girlfriend.
I let him sleep in my bed.
What is it?
He says,
it's like,
really?
I give,
I take sex from him if not a kill him.
Yeah.
I give him my food.
It's really dark African guy.
Yes.
I fucked him.
A new guy.
Come.
I fuck him.
Fuck him.
I have sex with him.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that well that,
yeah,
that,
that kind of shit.
Right.
If you find that pull,
pull that up because it's just the audio alone.
It's like scary.
Most evil prisoner of all time or something is what it's called or just beast.
Prisoner man might knock us off line,
but I'll try.
Yeah.
Sense of bitch and I just looked,
you might be right.
There might be nothing here.
I just looked on this website that checks everything.
Checks everything.
What?
Like Internet.
Yeah.
No,
trust me.
You're hiding.
We're in the,
we're in the woods.
Oh yeah.
We're in the woods of discovery.
We're going to get it worked out.
This sucks,
but it's online and the,
uh,
I'm looking at the video.
It's not that bad.
It's working,
but most importantly,
it's just got to go through a process.
This whole thing's going through a process.
That's part,
it's exciting to me.
I've never built anything before.
I've never liked slowly started and sort of organize and put it together and to
have it the way I want it.
Like,
I love that having the brick wall,
like a real brick wall.
I love the Oak table.
These lovely early days.
Yeah,
this is,
but I love,
I love like real shit like that.
Bricks and wood.
It makes me feel good.
That stuff.
That's the kind of like metal,
like cast iron,
like these,
these legs and shit.
The Werewolf sculpture.
Yeah,
that too.
Perfect.
I'm going to bring one of my boot into,
yeah.
Buddhist going to rocket in the corner and just watch over the old one.
Not The big one.
It's too hard to move the big ones too hard to move,
but I've got another one that's pretty big too.
It's going to go here.
Cool.
Match over us back.
Ingestions what else do I do?
This place
fucking have a float tank.
Yeah,
but that's,
no one's going to,
what are you going to do?
I'm going to have some going on there and they're going to be annoying.
Yeah,
man.
Float tank and then you give your pals keys to this place.
They can come out here and float.
Yeah,
come back or just go to the float was everywhere.
Whereas Float Lab Dunkin was here written in blood on the wall.
Oh yeah,
that guy did.
I would,
I would waste blood on
maybe a little period blood.
You won't.
Who knows?
Have you seen this blood blood bricks that they can make now?
It's a,
it's a brick that they take blood and they mix it with something and it makes a
brick and they're making houses out of these outbreaks.
Oh my God.
That's great.
Who's blind?
Uh,
I don't know.
How do you know there's not a couple of people mixed in your house?
Right?
Well,
no,
that's cool.
I'll tell you this.
If I was going to die,
I wouldn't mind somebody with drawing my blood and using it for blood bricks for
their house.
Would you rather that or Tibetans Sky Funeral,
Skype?
Well,
no,
both turn my blood and the bricks and let the buzzards eat me.
Oh,
well you can probably grind most of you and turn it into bricks.
Why?
Just fuck with the blood?
I don't know.
I know you just had blood bricks.
I wouldn't know.
I like I that whole idea of like the way we do death in this country is so god
damn sterile.
I'm fucked up.
What's a scam?
First of all,
those guys
gamma's that you have to pay for the funeral and then it's really expensive and
you know you have to pay a lot of money for a casket and you have to embalm the
body.
Even if you're going to,
they have it set up with the body gets involved.
I believe even if it gets cremated,
I think you still have to embalm the body.
I think that's the law
dude,
that Tibetans,
Scott ritual is such a beautiful fucking thing man.
When you watch someone turn into a bunch of birds,
that's really cool to watch that happen.
You guys have wills?
I don't.
Yeah,
I need one.
Do you know if you,
if you don't have a will,
I think I'm not 100% sure,
but like the government just takes all your shit.
Even if you have living parents and another state.
I got to get a,
well
that's true.
I think it goes to the next of kin,
Joe.
Joe,
if something happens to me,
dude,
you can have my little hub.
Oh.
And my computer.
I'll do,
that's all I want.
I own two things.
That's all I want.
I got pass again.
You got to piss again.
Oh my dude.
I drink so much coffee to Dan.
Go ahead.
We don't have much time left in this podcast,
unfortunately because,
uh,
I got a big,
stupid important meeting.
Where's it at side?
Because that highway was fucked.
I don't know if you got my text message.
There was like five cars,
all cop cars.
It seemed like that guy in a car accident and the whole freeway's closed.
Which freeway?
One one.
Oh,
great.
Woopsies oopsy daisy.
Well,
I'll try,
I'll try.
I'll try to make it,
but if I don't make it,
don't really give a fuck.
I hate to leave anybody hanging.
Yeah.
The more,
the more I think about yesterday's podcast,
I don't know if I want to say say it the more I think that guy is tweaker.
You think so?
Yeah.
Most people thought that a lot of people who,
uh,
listen then thought he was off and that he would like contradict himself.
And the fact that he knew so much about those drugs,
but yet there was a,
you know,
we read on Gizmodo that they didn't cite sources,
but they said,
you know,
sources close to him.
Say that he's always been interested in finding drugs that make women's sexual.
It kinda goes along with the whole 67 year old guy,
a 20 year old girlfriend thing.
You know,
it sounds like a dude who's just,
that's his thing.
I don't know.
I mean he,
he claims not,
but then he ought,
but he knows so much about that man.
How the fuck do you know so much about bath salts and MDPV and these different
hypersexual compounds and how could he tell us the exact chemical composition of
it?
Remember when he told us?
But it wouldn't actually was,
why would you say that unless you have great interest in it and why would you
have graded?
And then the other thing was saying like,
I have to be addicted.
It can't do that.
Then I would be on it right now and I sound like I don't on it.
He might be on it right now,
but I don't necessarily think that a strong willed man like that has to be
addicted to.
So it's supposedly really hypersexual.
That's the thing.
But I figured that if you're a gun,
a gun,
I'm like God,
like Mcafee,
he's,
you know,
he created this business.
He's like a very headstrong guy,
very powerful guy.
I kind of like that could probably quit of really fucking dangerous drug for a
little bit.
Sure.
You know,
he could,
it's,
it's hard to tell when someone lies about anything.
If they lie about anything or don't or not completely honest about anything,
you immediately have to look at the whole thing and go,
well,
if he's not telling the truth about doing those drugs and how can I listen to
all the other stuff?
Yeah.
It sounds,
it sounds like it's a lot of who the fuck knows what to believe at that at that
point,
and the fact that he has no charges,
nothing like on record like that.
Like there's no warrant for his arrest.
There's nothing,
it kind of made me think that he was just super paranoid.
Well,
it could be that.
It could be that,
you know,
I mean,
I told you there was that story that someone had said that he thought that there
was people outside and he had a conversation.
I heard this,
this you can get on wired this,
uh,
discussion.
Um,
it's just something,
hold on a second,
I'll find it because maybe we could pull it up and it's audio anyway.
A wired,
uh,
yeah.
Thank you.
It's McAfee off the rails.
Crazy audio.
Um,
but he was talking about how the,
there was these people and they were,
um,
they were standing there,
they were like military people and they were standing there and they didn't say
anything.
They just just stood there and he wouldn't move.
And so he just stood there too.
And they slowly went away like after hours and hours.
Like,
so he was like standing.
Then he was talking about like how,
how much his,
his uh,
arm hurt because he was like leaning up against this wall,
but he couldn't move.
He moved.
They would shoot him hand.
Yeah.
But there'll be more saying there's no footprints there.
There's like he's
was that house that somebody posted on your message board?
The guy that died,
like it was like a shack that had an American flag in it.
And I don't know.
No,
I don't know whose house that was.
Yeah.
Does it that it was what it was supposed to.
I thought that I thought the guy,
somebody that died because it was like this.
I mean it looked like a shack.
Like it just looked like a junkyard shack,
you know?
Yeah.
He's fucking,
I don't know man.
Yeah,
I could,
that was an interesting podcast cause I kept on thinking about it after,
when I got home.
And then the more I thought about it was just like,
you know,
this just seems like something's not right.
It was cool
that he,
he,
um,
was willing.
Yeah.
You know,
it was cool that he did it.
I feel like I'm just getting trolled though.
Maybe that's what it seems like.
It doesn't,
it seems like smells like a big old troll.
Yeah.
I hope so.
Um,
I'm trying to find in this,
uh,
I'm trying to find this because it's really interesting.
I really want to want to play it.
Okay.
Here it is.
If you go to a audio,
just look this Google search says audio McAfee's still in hiding predicts they
will track me down and there's a brilliant man.
The picture of him was him of course,
shirtless with a gun,
another different photo of him shirtless with a gun like apparently posed for
quite a few photos while holding it.
Macafee predicts during podcasts being broadcast to millions of people.
They will track me down.
Uh,
but he's,
uh,
you know,
I appreciate the fact that the guy was willing to talk to us.
I mean,
it was pretty interesting to be able to talk to someone who's in this a crazy
scenario.
Yes.
That's cool.
He was a crazy person and a crazy scenario.
It sounds like he's an eccentric,
you know,
definitely think,
I mean,
that's a lot of what it takes to become some super millionaire type character
that,
yeah,
it's true.
I mean,
that's the thing,
man.
You've got to be able to like,
let your mind go into the weird places,
but you gotta be able to come back.
Do you see this picture button?
This is the one that,
that's the audio you wait for,
wait for it to pull up.
Is it Polo?
Yeah,
it's,
um,
the whole story is so compelling.
It's so hunters Thompson ask like,
this guy just goes off the rails on an island.
67 years old,
20 year old girlfriends.
Yeah.
Pictures of him with guns.
Surrounded by dogs.
He's got 11 dogs.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
wow.
It's like Pharaoh.
He went Pharrel's amazing.
And he has all these lawsuits that are coming after him and he will not pay.
He's like,
I simply will not pay.
He goes,
uh,
I will,
I,
I will spend $10 million to fight it,
to give them nothing.
What are the lawsuits about?
Well,
one of them was about,
he had this,
he was connected to this,
uh,
sort of a sport where they would fly.
These looked like motorcycles that are attached to kite wings.
It's really crazy.
And they're really maneuverable.
Apparently what they would do,
these low altitude,
you know,
not even altitude low off,
I mean basically just very close to the ground.
They would do these things like acrobatics spin around on these fucking plants.
Whole swing crashed and died.
Right.
And so he got sued and that's when he decided apparently to move to beliefs,
you just loaded up his truck and he moved to bevel a just get the fuck out.
And I guess Billy's won't extradite him or something.
I don't know how it works,
but if,
if he apparently says that if he loses the court cases,
it doesn't matter.
They'll just come and take his money.
Like if,
if you lose,
you lose.
But that he doesn't believe that he's guilty because he wasn't even driving it.
He wasn't a response.
He wasn't responsible for maintaining it.
It wasn't his,
you know what I mean?
It's like it wasn't his fault.
This guy died like this,
but apparently he was like working hard to promote this crazy sort of a sport.
John McAfee,
who was calling to tell me that the police were closing in.
He had spent the night and an undisclosed house in Belize sleeping on a bed
infested with lice and that he felt that the end was near,
that they would arrest him at any minute,
but he was not going to surrender because he was convinced that they would kill
him.
I've been following McAfee's case and believes for the past six months,
ever since April 30th when the police raided him and accused him of being a drug
trafficker and possessing illegal firearms.
Uh,
over those six months,
I've spent weeks and Billy's and interviewed McAfee both in person and on the
telephone,
probably over a hundred hours of interviews.
And I can say without a doubt that he is a very complex person,
but whether or not is a murderer is yet to be seen.
I recorded McAfee's phone calls to me this morning with his permission.
And what follows are those calls,
one of the charges against you is that you're a psychopath.
What do you have to say about Tom?
I would not be confidence or to uh,
to comment on it,
yes or no,
then I either one if I were a psychopath would be irrelevant.
I don't think I'm a psychopath.
I liked people.
I think psychopaths are,
are sort of anti social folks that hey people,
I tend to love people.
I tend to love people in spite of their faults,
in spite of the things that they do or attempt to do.
To me.
You're well aware of,
of Marcy for example,
who,
who plotted for for three months they have me kidnapped for money and um,
yeah,
whenever she,
she lived with me after that for two additional months before they finally got
too intense.
This is a good question.
Why do you surround yourself with people of questionable character?
Well,
I surround myself with people of club on questionable character to Eddie and
Kona is,
I don't know,
a more honest,
a god fearing person yourself.
So I think I'd be friended to and,
and,
and embraced you as I embraced anyone else.
Not even the audio that I was looking for,
unfortunately.
Pretty good.
But the
other one was better because it was really nuts
do,
when I worked at the comedy store,
there was this lady who would call,
I can't remember her name,
but she would call and like I,
I,
she is interesting her the way that her insanity function,
cause she'd call and be like,
she would always say she used to work out their camera name,
but then she'd like start being like,
yes,
you know?
Yeah.
Last Wednesday,
three men came into my house and they raped me and laughed and you know,
like we'd slip in these really weird hardcore story.
She called a few times and it was always like these plots against her,
you know,
they,
they did like,
you know,
I was kidnapped.
Uh,
she was just making things up.
She had,
but she believed it.
And you know what I mean?
It's like when your mind,
I'm not saying I don't know about Maca.
I don't know.
Who knows?
Maybe he's all together and he's totally there.
People were really plotting against him.
I mean,
rich people live in a different land.
But it's interesting how like people who are paranoid,
the way it comes out,
it's not like they're gonna be like everybody's
see that people are looking to kidnap him.
She has been plotting to kidnap me and for,
so when I'm,
when someone starts talking and that sort of matter of factly,
there's,
there's a disconnect there from reality as well.
Dude,
we gotta end this pocket.
Oh,
get the fuck out of here.
I'm so sorry,
but we'll do it again quite soon.
Cool.
Let's try it again as often as possible please.
Powerful,
powerful Dunkin proper Brian driving all the way over here for 40 minutes of use
stream.
You're the fucking man.
Uh,
and uh,
we will be back tomorrow at 3:00 PM here with the Great Eddie Bravo.
So,
uh,
we're going to have some fun and then this weekend,
um,
Dunkin,
me and just three of us in this room will be in Austin,
Texas and we will be performing at Austin city limits.
Should be really fun at the Moody Theater.
It's called and a fucking really looking forward to that.
We don't get a chance to go to Austin that often.
Austin,
I love Austin.
One of the grades.
I wouldn't marry us.
I would marry the Fucker to Austin.
It's a great setup.
Definitely Mary Austin,
Austin come this,
this show had no commercials in the beginning.
You will have none of the end.
I am sorry sponsors,
but go fuck yourself today.
A profit on it.com that's it.
Show's over.
Go to Duncan Trussell,
T R U s s e l l and follow his APP,
Duncan trussell.com iron lord meets shift challenge.
If you want to get in shape and December,
we're all going to get in shape together.
Yes,
he's got to meet,
shift challenge.
Everyone that is connected to this must commit to doing what is absolutely
necessary and writing all your shit down and getting shaped and Dunkin's.
I got a trainer.
He's going to be on the podcast every week.
Yeah.
Fucking psyched.
I'm,
I love to hear that man.
Brian UN.
No.
All right,
we'll,
we'll uh,
see you guys tomorrow.
Thank you very much.
God bless your mother fucker.
See Ya.
Okay.
Yeah.